Seve Stevenson the Cleveland shooter I
don't himself after a brief pursuit in
in Pennsylvania I want to get into
something here because the family of the
man who was murdered in cold blood
actually I think surprised Anderson
Cooper with their response to a question
and I think this this ties into a larger
issue we see this a lot online so I want
to try and handle this tactfully I don't
want to alienate people I don't expect
you to agree with everything that I'm
saying everything that they're saying
but the ice divide right now between New
Atheism and in traditional Christianity
I think this is illuminating socia that
I would take away the most when my
father is he taught us about God how to
fear God how to love God and how to
forgive and each one of us forgive
killer murderer you do we want to wrap
our arms around yeah we absolutely do we
don't I honestly can say right now but I
hold no animosity against in my heart
against this man because I know that
he's an individual I know that you know
because of the sickness whatever evil
overtook him that caused him to do this
to my dad if not him it wouldn't be
something he would typically do and I
promise you I could not do that if I did
not know God if I didn't know him as my
dad in my Savior I could not forgive
that man Wow
powerful words from a family whether you
agree with them or not I know some
people are going to well listen there's
no more justice the man shot himself in
the head and don't confuse I'm about to
say with being an advocacy for for mercy
in place of justice that's certainly not
it but you know we see this a lot we've
had the next D'Souza on and we've had
sargon we've had a pretty brilliant
Christian apologist theologians on we've
had two pretty well-known atheists on I
think this is pretty important to see
because there's this idea first off that
religions are the cause of all wars
right you hear that a lot
let's do away with that that's not even
close to true of the 1763 wars waged
over the course of human history
that we can measure only 123
have been classified as being fought
over a religious cause let's look at
some of the modern wars in case people
don't believe me the American Revolution
the French Revolution the American Civil
War World War one the Russian expansion
of communism world war two North Korea
Vietnam
none of these were religious wars now
people who fought them were some people
who were leaders in those wars were
deeply ideological of course you see it
with people like Stalin who was deeply
atheist Lee ideological it was an idiot
idiot GA see ISM there was an ism you
may not like to hear it but his atheism
really was borderline religious in his
practice and certainly in his
imperialist attempt to expand it so it's
important to note that you can't remove
the faith from the individual but you
can't also say because these individuals
were religious that the wars were fought
over religion they can be fought over
territory they can be part of a
resources that's important to know our
foundational principle certainly in
Western culture come from Christianity
Milo talked about that dinesh d'souza I
mean you obviously look at people like
CS Lewis or you go back to Chesterton
these people talked about how if it's
all situational ethics if there is no
foundation that there is moral decay no
I've heard compelling arguments on both
sides of that
dinesh d'souza for example argues that
if you look at the totality of human
history basically all technological
innovation in history that we know today
loomed after the spread of Christendom
and there's a counter argument there to
be made that well that's also during the
great Empire of China anyways very
interesting and very interesting by the
way the ideologies if you look at people
who were on these sides of the war for
example deeply Christian look at the way
the Americans treated prisoners of war
compared to the Japanese or compared to
the Russians this idea I want to attack
a little bit a few say if you if you
need a book societies don't need
religion to dictate morality if you need
a book to tell you not kill someone from
some spaghetti monster in the sky you're
crazy you're a bad person okay you know
what let's take that maybe do not kill
is an international language of morality
maybe most people know that stealing is
wrong let's say that none of those come
from societal conditioning or in Western
culture from conditioning through deeply
Christian philosophy okay let's go with
that
but the idea
here the moral idea of forgiving your
enemies of showing love to your enemies
that is not something that people hold
to be intrinsically moral that is not
something that a society could possibly
embrace if it weren't a Christian
society now you may not think that's a
good moral Muslims don't laveyan
satanism we'll get to that but that is a
distinctly Christian moral premise love
your enemies that is not some of the
human beings do naturally on their own
so yeah you do need a kind of a Flying
Spaghetti Monster in the sky to tell you
that you know what your instinct is to
hate your enemies you're in thingsit's
to seek revenge and vengeance justice is
right serve justice I'll give you a
board plan I'll give you a blueprint how
to serve justice but do not hate and act
in revenge
that's a distinctly Christian idea it
goes against human nature Luke 6:27 says
but to you who are listening I say love
your enemies do good to those who hate
you bless those who curse you pray for
those who mistreat you Luke 632 235 says
if you love those who love you what
credit is that to you even sinners love
those who love them and if you do good
to those who are good to you what credit
is that to you even sinners do that and
if you lend to those from whom you
expect repayment what credit is that to
you even sinners lend to sinners
expecting to be repaid in full but love
your enemies do good to them and lend to
them without expecting to get anything
back this is something else a lot of ACS
say well religions are the cause of all
wars there's also not an equivalency
between religions because you contrast
the overarching premise of love your
enemies
all right justice is mine but love your
enemies treat them well as you see this
family that isn't incredibly the reason
that's news reading people are talking
about it is because it goes against
every single instinct that we have as
human beings and I don't necessarily
think that's wrong you see someone shoot
your father you see someone kill your
family it's natural to want to take take
the issue into your own hands and I
don't necessarily think that it's
immoral for that man to be punished
severely
but having a book a moral guideline say
hey don't act on exactly what it is you
want to do that cannot occur in a
society that does not have some kind of
foundational principles in our in our
case biblical let's contrast that as an
equivalency with a religion like Islam
Quran verse 545 life for life eye for
eye nose for nose ear for ear tooth for
tooth and wounds equal for equal took
the eye for an eye a little bit further
one out of trail that one apparently we
had the abridged version
here's one from Sura notably to verse
244 then fighting the cause of Allah and
know that Allah heareth and knoweth all
things look looking historically we've
talked about this jail except
Christianity when it started spreading
right this is a time where if you were a
first martyr Stephen if you were a known
Christian you were killed okay that's
when Christianity boomed at that point
and Christianity during that period was
spread by word of mouth okay known
oppressors you profess to be Christian
dead spread by word of mouth now
contrast that with Islam which when it
was created there were no known direct
oppressors during its greatest expansion
period always spread by the sword Islam
has only throughout history been spread
through birth rate because these people
copulate like rabbits for at the tip of
a sword that's how Islam is spread the
main spreading of Christianity was
through word of mouth Gerald am i
incorrect no you're absolutely correct I
mean that's how you can you can kind of
validate the Christian religion as well
people don't die for a cause that isn't
real right and so you can commit the
early martyrs who had actually known
Christ yeah exactly right and then kind
of going through the system there but
you're right it's always through
conquests and through just having kids
into the field away grows the rules in
Islam Gerald knows is convert if you
don't convert you're killed or subjected
to Dimmie to do with all kinds of taxes
and your rights are removed from your
self minutes so these are your only
three options that's why there's almost
no Islamic charity outside of Islam they
don't have a lot of Islamic Islamic bank
sales going on they're not going into
Haiti at the same rates or into Africa
helping people helping create houses it
Christian Church is creating very
secular missionary works helping people
just in the name of Christ you don't see
that from Islam globally in the name of
Islam people who aren't Muslim it
doesn't happen again so we're taught
let's let's go back down the trail this
is not something that would exist in a
society without it being prescribed
the idea of loving your enemies if you
look at other religions it is not
prescribed and if you look at the
results they are two very different
pathways and if you look at Islam
actually has much more similar with
laveyan satanism now by the way not all
Satanist or laveyan satanism levain
Satanists based it basically means it's
practiced atheistic religion they don't
really believe in God they sort of see
it as mythology but they believe that
the character of Satan is more powerful
because they believe that they are their
own God and so the idea of satan
rebelling against God is sort of seen as
a parable for lilian Satanists and they
they actually like the guy who rebelled
against God Satan represents vengeance
instead of turning the other cheek state
represents kindness to those who deserve
it not love wasted on ingrates and
that's actually pretty common throughout
the history of the world before Christ
and most places that do not involve
Christ again I don't care if you're an
atheist so we just need to acknowledge
the different effects that different
religions and worldviews have the idea
of loving your enemy didn't exist it's
terrible that you would think that these
things just come about naturally it
doesn't look at kids kids who have no
social conditioning whatsoever are
selfish they're absolutely out for their
own needs and basically that's humanism
until you're telling the world that
there is no God you're your own God do
what you want
well we've seen what happens in cultures
when you do what you want bad people
come to power millions of people die
every single time right yeah and of
course obviously some people will argue
less pre-emptive that some people have
used the mantle of Christianity to
manipulate and become bad people in
power and kill lots of people that has
happened yes yes absolutely of the
feasts let's go back to Christ go but it
could contrast that with Mohammed
contrast that with the ancient Egyptian
religions contrast that with with
laveyan satanism it's not the same and
that's why these kinds of reports are
powerful why is it news because you go
oh my gosh could I what I want to hug
someone who murdered my father you know
what it's incredibly difficult to do and
that's the concept through Christianity
of dying to flesh I'm just if you're an
atheist hopefully you're learning being
educated here just as to what Christians
believe dying to yourself every day if
you hear that term it's the meaning of
actually not giving in to your basic
even carnal instincts and you see that
here and that is not something that you
will find in any society just through
happens
if you like this clip it's taken from
the fold Daily Show available
exclusively a lot of credit calm slash
mug club that's for mug club members
because we can't be dependent here in
the Google YouTube overlords subscribe
there we have a Daily Show full hour
every day if you don't well there's no
saving you